you always have to fight for things that
are worth it so boring everyone's doing
the same thing
are you walking the dog or is the dog
walk in you the more brilliant people
that you hang around more inspired you
get we're living in an age in a society
now where that is almost looked at as a
weakness you turn the applecart over and
then what then everyone's looking out an
apple cart is turned over and they're
like well now what do I do in my mind
there's a little movie playing and I
always envision scenarios and characters
you could never compare you know Picasso
with mache I always tell people
vacations are for people who don't like
their job
I want to conquer the world she's an
American singer songwriter actress and
businesswoman she pushed the boundaries
in her music and videos she sold over
300 million records and she is the
world's best-selling female recording
artist of all time she's Madonna and
hear her top 10 rules for success so
well I I think the best advice I can
give anyone male or female is that you
know you have to really believe in what
you're doing I think having a good job
and having work is um it's hard it's
hard to come by and being able to do
what you want to do with your life so
you have to be willing first of all you
have to be really passionate about what
you do and really believe in what you do
because there's going to be a lot of
fights and battles and struggles along
the way so my best advice is to really
believe in love what you do because um
because at the end of the day nothing
you know you you always have to fight
for things that are worth it so put your
boxing gloves on will we ever see
choreography in a video again
major dancing it's possible it's just
that I got so sick of all the videos
everybody's making where there's like
the troupe of dancers and the singer
standing in front of it nobody was
moving in unison I thought so boring
everyone's doing the same thing so I
wanted to get away from all of that but
yeah I could see doing something like
that actually because now not so many
people are doing it so be something
different you will definitely always go
against the grain won't you well I will
always take the road less traveled but
we're all controlled by our ego we are
all slaves our ego everything we do is
about our ego guilty as charged and so
am i and so are we all and if I didn't
have a huge ego I wouldn't be here um
but at a certain point you have to
understand that it is you know it's your
dog and it's like are you walking the
dog or is the dog walking you the best
way to be inspired as an artist is to be
around humanity whether you're walking
down the street or you're standing in
the middle of a shopping mall or you're
hanging around about a lot of really
brilliant people I mean you know that
the smarter I mean the more brilliant
people that you hang around more
inspired you get you know so I just like
to be around talented people whether I
use what I learned from them in my work
or not I always say to myself why why
are people inspired by everything that
I've accomplished why's everybody afraid
you know I think my strengths and that's
like the hardest thing that I've had to
sort of grasp and accept is that my
surviving and my strength and the things
that I've accomplished
isn't isn't inspirational to other
people it's frightening I think and I
think it's because so many people are so
afraid to to have a point of view to to
strike out on their own and to like try
and realize one of their dreams and to
see someone else doing it we're living
in an age in a society now where that is
almost looked at as a weakness something
to be ashamed of
most people are immobilized by the fear
of failure yeah absolutely when they see
someone else doing really well it's like
I think deep down inside it's human
nature to want to destroy them to try to
destroy them to try to bring them down
to your level so you can feel good about
yourself do you have got a really good
job though I think of making the rest of
us think you don't care very much with
other people and a good actress I mean
I'm a rebel and you know that's the
stance of a rebel the stance of a rebel
is you know I can't say bad words on TV
but you know I don't care what you think
but it's if it's just for the sake of
upsetting the applecart you're not
really helping people
you turn the applecart over and then
what then everyone's looking at an apple
cart is turned over and they're like
well now what do I do
so you've done a little of that God just
for the sake of it just for the sake of
it I like when I write music I like to
write them like in my mind there's a
little movie playing and I always
envision scenarios and characters and of
course it's not always something that
I've experienced but I always say it in
the first person so it becomes it seems
like it's a personal thing and they're
just usually ideas that amuse me
I mean sometimes the things that I think
are erotic sometimes they're things that
I think would be interesting to write a
song about because no one's ever written
a song about it you know I mean I I'm
influenced by many things and my
inspirations come from lots of different
places and sometimes I know I'm
purposely being funny or ironic you know
and sometimes I'm just I just like the
way words sound I mean I just think that
people it's it's pointless for people to
get into a creative arena and say I want
to be the best I mean you know there are
everyone has
they have they'd say what they say and
you could never compare you know Picasso
with Lachey I mean you have to everybody
has something different to say um and
it's silly to get in there and say my
brushstroke is better than another
person's you know it's better to say am
i being true to myself and is this what
I want to say and have I expressed
myself you know the way I want to
express myself no I mean that's what
it's all about
would you are you trying to would you
like to find another Madonna well I
don't think that's possible huh
but I'm what I'm trying to find is
really I don't know
fresh talent that that's saying
something cutting edge new I mean we
found so many good groups we signed a
couple groups so far and I'm really
excited about them this obviously is
going to be more work for you presumably
it is already more work for me well I'm
not saying this person but some people
perhaps would think if they had that
much success if they had that much well
maybe one thing they'd want to do is
while they were still young enough to
enjoy all this maybe take a year off
kick around the world you know go
fishing whatever but I enjoy what I do I
mean life is short my have lots of
things to do and I see talent out there
and I want to do something with it I
mean I like watching I like planting
seeds and watching it grow know what I
mean it's it's inspiring do you actually
do actually take a holiday go hmm what
is that I mean I always tell people
vacations are for people who don't like
their job I like what I do what I would
like to ultimately achieve I already
told Dick Clark once on American
Bandstand so I repeat it again and um
and annoy everyone who was annoyed
before when I said it I want to conquer
the world
thank you so much for watching as we
made this video because anna yang asked
us to if there's someone else that you'd
like us to profile please leave it in
the comments and we'll see what we can
do we also love to know which one of
Madonna's top ten rules meant the most
to you leave it in the comments below
and we'll join the discussion thank you
so much for watching continue to believe
and we'll see you soon
my Kabbalah teacher one of the
to say to me when in doubt act like God
and then you think what does that mean
you know it's like well what didn't
describe God God would be compassionate
unconditional all giving all loving so
when in doubt behave that way you'll
you'll never go wrong if you like Big
Bob do you like pot who doesn't
oh not everybody Julie UNIX name one
person who doesn't like power everybody
wants to be famous no it's not it's not
just Fame its power is anyone can have
power I mean it's it's a it's it's how
you feel about yourself it's how you
carry yourself it's the effect that you
have on people it doesn't necessarily
it's not synonymous with fame and I
think that I don't think you would find
a human being on this earth that wasn't
interested in power I think that two
years ago I wasn't really sure why what
I was on this earth for I think I was
mostly concerned with getting things for
myself you know more clothes more money
more popularity more approval more
boyfriends more every you know it was
just like no I mean it was I wasn't
really thinking I was just doing hmm so
not living consciously really yeah yeah
and and I think I probably had some
conscious moments I think I was like
brain-dead but um but but you know what
I mean obviously like a lot of people
are just kind of going through the
motions no matter what your motions are
can't do that yeah no I think I just
kind of woke up and said okay what am I
on this earth for why are we all on this
earth for we're here to love we're here
to share that's it so that's the
difference
totally